but sometimes every now and again it's
worse than just incompetence the same
people who see racism everywhere well I
should say racism everywhere except
where it actually it is actually is they
bring on people like ilhan Omar ilhan
Omar who married her brother
Google it it's true eventually they'll
remove it from Google she married her
brother she is a really awful person she
has been all for defunding the police
she is absolutely destroyed Minneapolis
she hates America despite being a first
generation immigrant who moved here from
Somalia became incredibly powerful and
she spends every day trying to undermine
this country that has been far far too
good for someone like her well she was
on CNN yesterday talking to Dana Bash
and Dana asked her about her previous
anti-semitic competent comments and
here's some double speak for you
so when you apologized uh for the all
about the Benjamin's comment you said
anti-Semitism is real and I'm grateful
for Jewish allies and colleagues who are
educating me on the painful history of
anti-Semitic tropes what did you learn
a lot
um I certainly did not or was not aware
that the word hypnotized was a Trope
um I wasn't aware
um of of the fact that there are tropes
about Jews and money that has been a
very enlightening uh part of of this
journey yeah it's been so enlightening
of course she knew exactly what she is
doing she's just a like there's nothing
we can do with these people
like there's nothing we can say about
them that would shame them and then Adam
Schiff and Adam Schiff
I did not I wasn't sure of this I had to
Google it he's Jewish and I just like to
say as a Jew we apologize if I have to
write a letter to somebody and just like
we don't want anything to do with Adam
Schiff I'll gladly do it but he sits
there knowing he is sitting with this
vile racist woman and he does not say a
word but how hilarious is that's what
the panel on CNN is it's Adam Schiff
Adam Schiff who completely made up the
Russia collusion hoax who now is running
for Senate he's a congressman he's now
running for Senate in Cali so we'll
probably get him it'll be even worse in
California you have him you have Eric
swalwell was the other guy sitting there
he's the one that slept with the Chinese
spy and you know it's true because the
media refuses to debunk it and Kevin
McCarthy keeps saying it and then you
have ilhan Omar who basically is an
islamist and and at some level is at the
very least I mean she's deeply
anti-American she defunded the police in
Minneapolis they destroyed Minneapolis
and then she blamed the police for not
doing their job on top of marrying her
brother and a whole bunch of other stuff
these are awful awful human beings right
they really there's just no other way to
say it if that is what you use your
power for I don't know how I can
describe you anyway
[Music]